how
many previous sexual partners is too
many
212.
oh no sorry you I thought you were
asking me about my own personal Craft
um right so I did some work with Steve
on this and you're gonna really enjoy
this because we've got a follow-up study
that I'm just writing up at the moment
so we did this study in 2018 I think
2017 2018. it actually so this is one of
my claim to fame this got written up in
Playboy so so that's like you know oh
we've made it
um so we basically said you know for a
long-term partner here's a person
they're generally attractive how willing
would you be to go on a date with them
or entertain them as a long-term partner
based on what people now call body count
but when we did the research was just
having sexual partners they've had and
you've I still remember walking into
Steve's office and him having on the
screen where he'd plotted up the data
he's got the the nicest curve ever and
he was like yeah I'm writing this up
it's a lovely lovely curve and it
basically Peaks at around about four
being like the optimal uh three to four
what's really really cool is it's not
just a linear pattern so it's not like
three to four and then it just goes
downhill you get this little curve so
people are a bit wary about a virgin as
well
uh it's still high so being a virgin is
I think equivalent to something like
having 12 Partners something like that
um yeah being of oh no it's less than
that it's seven to eight Partners is the
equivalent of kind of being a virgin is
this male to female female to male is
there a gen a sex difference here this
it depends on uh again sexual strategy
so if you're just looking at a long-term
relationship the lines are so close
together you could squint and they look
the same
where you get the difference is for a
short-term partner and then men's
standards drop
um compared to women but for a long for
a long-term partner no the nice sort of
curve shape is about the same how
different is a woman's short-term and
long-term curve
uh it's a little bit flatter
um so if they're looking for a
short-term relationship whether someone
has two partners or like 12 Partners
it's
pretty similar right it's pretty similar
so it flattens out a little bit the
curve is sort of less steep uh but it's
still much higher than guys
what do you think that it says that
having uh a virgin or somebody with one
partner is less desirable than somebody
with three or four is this stated in
revealed preferences again or is there
something else going on I think that
this is
so you've got to think it's all it's a
U-shaped curve at the end of the day and
there's almost like you you shape uh
u-shaped risks associated with so risks
on either end so
the risk to having someone with zero
sexual partners is that there might be a
reason for it there might be a reason
that they're a virgin so it could be
that they're just not a good deal it
could be that they have low made value
so it could be that you're actually
completely overestimating how good a
catch this person is it's a kind of a
free selection yeah once you enter into
a relationship and you start investing
you don't want to be investing in
someone who is not the best deal for you
on the other end when you have people
have too many sexual partners then you
have things like sexually transmitted
disease if you want a long-term
relationship the chances of them maybe
cheating on you or leaving is is
probably is probably quite a bit higher
um and so there's risks all round but
the higher number I believe associated
with different risks than the lower
numbers
but interesting I'm doing a follow-up
study so this one was in uh the Journal
of sex research and it was just on a UK
sample
um so I thought right how can we just
like inject some steroids into this
thing so I've redone it
but we've done it with 10 countries so
UK Poland Norway Japan
Brazil all over the place yeah
um and not only are we now looking at
numbers but we're looking at when the
numbers were
because what I realized is that if
you're asking people about 12 partners
and they may they can make a judgment
but then if you were to say it's 12
partners and 11 of those have been in
the last three months
that's very different to 11 of them were
around about when that person was 18 19
and 20 and then recently they've only
had one or two gee so I mean numbers the
same but if you were going to pick
someone for a long-term relationship
that's going to commit to you and you
might get married to and have kids too
which one are you going for there's
someone who clearly was a bit sexually
desirable in their youth and has calmed
down a bit or someone who's actually
pretty active now on a tear at the
moment uh yeah absolutely so um yeah so
we've got that I'm just plotting up the
data at the moment isn't it interesting
that some of the common men's advice on
the internet especially around
pre-selection uh you know there's a big
push at the moment for the polygyny
thing that most girls will happily take
a high value man if you know he's
sufficiently high value and she'll
happily share him and so on and so forth
that doesn't seem to be borne out in
this data given the fact that men's
preference for partners especially over
the long term and women's doesn't
diverge all that much now it doesn't
seem like women's because because the
body count in a man as being a some sort
of pre-selection uh attractor
and there's there's some work I'm doing
at the moment I keep saying this I've
got more studies than I have time to
write them up and I'm doing some work
with um Leif canaire at the moment about
the sexual double standards because you
you almost have sexual double standards
at a global level and a personal level
so the global level is like or the
societal level is what do you think
society says
and that's when you sort of get
narratives like well
um girls don't care about a guy's body
count but guys care about a girl's body
count of the sort of societal level but
whenever you measure it at the personal
level so what an individual actually
thinks
very little evidence for the sexual
double standard
so it's one of these things where we
actually think it's a thing but when you
actually talk to someone it turns out
not really to be a thing what do you
think that says about our own sexuality
in the way that we perceive other
people's
I think that it's it says that sometimes
our uh mating theory of mind can be
quite faulty
um I think that there's
culture wars all over the shop including
between men or women these days and I
think it ends up in a place where the
Sexes become quite caricatured
especially based on maybe the most
extreme examples
um so again one of the most common one
is that people will apply short-term
mating psychology of men
to men so they will assume that the men
who are only after short-term
relationships and what they want they
will say all men are like that even
those who are looking for long-term
relationships
um and I I actually think a lot of
suffering in in the dating world comes
from
conflating short-term and long-term
mating desires so either you're after
something long-term
um but you're picking someone who's
after something short-term
that causes a lot of um confusion or
thinking that you want something
long-term when you actually want
something short term which I think is
also quite interesting the number of
people I've met who say that they want
to get married and have kids and settle
down but then you ask them what their
make preferences are and they just reel
you off all of the short-term mating
preferences and then of the long-term
mating preferences it's like well
actually it sounds like you just want a
short-term partner because you don't
care about kindness you don't care about
whether they want kids you don't care
about
um uh whether they can they're good
communicators or whether they can
empathize well you just care about do
they look good are they good in bed are
they going to give me resources now
um so yeah a lot of people are playing
the short-term game when they think
they're playing the long term game I
wonder whether
that would be I wonder whether that
would have a sexed difference I would
imagine that given women not wanting to
seem easy not wanting to come across
like they are not valuing their body in
the same sort of way that you may find
that women will
use I'm after a long-term mate as
perhaps even their own self-deception in
order to perhaps pursue short-term
mating goals
I don't know
it's an interesting so to round out that
um optimal number of Partners was it
almost exactly the same for men and
women it was about four
yeah
yeah I've got it here in front of me now
about four I mean this was three to four
this was a few years ago mine so we're
gonna see
um the we're going to see the difference
in the new study I mean one of the
things well one of the things that we
have done is we've looked at like four
versus 12 versus 36
um and the distribution patterns because
we show people actual physical
distribution patterns so here's one that
shows that it was recent
um distribute that four obviously is
still an optimal there's no effect
effective distribution for four so it
doesn't matter when people had Partners
four is like a nice solid number
um it's when you have the larger numbers
that's when it matters more of when when
did that happen is that something in
your past or not
um and once you actually send a load of
those into the past the difference
between say 4 12 and 36 start to
converge a little bit so it gets to the
point where the difference is become
minimal so that's quite interesting it
adds that extra Dimension what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]
oh